hey wisecrack Jared here okay so we're
gonna do something a little risky a
little crazy and maybe even a little
sacrilegious we're criticizing Pixar
because even though it's brought us the
tear-jerking joys of inside-out wall-e
and the Toy Story saga it's genius is
not entirely above some sloppy
storytelling turns out no studio can
resist the allure of a cash grabby
sequel and that's kind of what 2016's
finding dory felt like to us it just
didn't seem as emotionally resonant as
Pixar's best work and being the
obsessive nerds that we are here at
wisecrack we had to ask ourselves why
it's worth mentioning here that
according to the Guardian finding Dory
underwent massive rewrites were those
rewrites to blame for our
dissatisfaction with the movie is
finding Dory a lesser film than Finding
Nemo is this simply a case of sequel
itis are we just over fish stories
well let's fillet this thing and find
out welcome to eyes crack edition on
finding dory what went wrong and as
always spoilers ahead but before we dive
in thanks to the team at LastPass who
helped make this video possible like
every one you're probably tempted to use
the same few passwords over and over
again I mean seriously coming up with
hard to crack passwords and remembering
where you've used them it's just a pain
using the same passwords again and again
is a pretty bad idea psyched like Tumblr
LinkedIn even Domino's have been hacked
before and with a constant flow of new
data breaches it's nearly impossible to
keep track of which hacked site could be
jeopardizing your online security
that's where LastPass comes in it's an
online password manager that can help
you protect yourself and preserve your
sanity
not only does LastPass help you to
create secure passwords but it also
manages them for you no more hassles no
more remembering which passwords is for
which site
no more forgetting where you wrote them
down no more getting locked out of your
own accounts you can safely and easily
surf the net and avoid having to enter
the first concert you ever went to or
your grandmother's cousins maiden name
the free version is great and if you
want the premium features like family
sharing and priority support it's just a
couple bucks a month
thanks the LastPass for sponsoring this
video and check them out in the link in
the description to get started and now
on with the show finding Dory comes up
short in at least four key areas were
finding Nemo excels for the sake of
clarity let's categorize
these problems as one clouded emotional
investment too shaky narrative structure
three passive heroism and four
purposeless entourage to be fair these
issues are almost impossible to separate
from one another so there will
inevitably be some overlap but here we
go anyway first the question of
emotional investment a key objective of
any screenplay is to get the audience to
care deeply about the protagonist a goal
that's often achieved by first getting
us to care about whatever our
protagonist most values and/or needs may
be the protagonist is focused on scoring
an internship or going the distance in
the boxing ring or on breaking free of a
suffocating life whatever the case in
most strong screenplays that desire is
established early it's singular it's
powerful and it generates our empathy in
finding Nemo and finding Dory the
protagonist goals are blatantly similar
in the first film Marlin searches for
his kidnapped son in the second Dory
searches for the parents she hazily
remembers although there's nothing wrong
with leaning on the trope of the missing
family member I mean it works for Liam
Neeson finding nemo and finding dory
unfortunately have different attitudes
toward the magnitude of loss that's
because only one of these films offers
us a baseline before it rips a loved one
away and it's that baseline that creates
emotional connection between us the
protagonist and the protagonists need in
other words even though the bulk of
Finding Nemo keeps Marlon and Nemo apart
it first offers a sense of what these
family members mean to one another as
early as the first minute of finding
Nemo we're told what Marlin values more
than anything else in the world these
are our kids we're talking about they
deserve the best and Marlin proves that
value system through his actions in the
film's baseline moments we see Marlin
pledged to protect his son then teased
his son then prepare his son for school
then bring his son to school and then
lecture his son we have a sense of
history
so when Nemo gets kidnapped 15 minutes
into the film
we like Marlin have loved and we have
lost we are invested finding dory offers
no such baseline so it never offers the
gut punch delivered by its predecessor
in fact dory
her parents within the first five
minutes of finding dory in the opening
scene of the film dory even to her own
parents is positioned as something of a
liability
a cute little goof okay sweetheart what
about that rhyme we learned do you see
the undertow and we say let's go no no
surely thereafter like bubbles in a
bathtub her parents have vanish how much
can we really be expected to pour our
emotions into losing characters we never
knew we're your parents if finding dory
can't get much mileage out of a
parent-child bond that energized Finding
Nemo then what is the central
relationship here where do we invest our
empathy you might guess that we feed
into the bond between Marlin and dory
after all they did spend a whole movie
together they're probably totally buds
now right know what you can do Dory you
can go wait over there go wait over
there and forget that's what you do best
not really seems the arc of personal
growth that marlin and Dory experienced
in Finding Nemo has reverted here with
dory now being viewed as a nuisance by
pretty much everyone sadly it isn't
until Dory is separated from the
relationships she formed in the first
film that were introduced to what is
supposed to be her source of support in
this movie
the bond between Dory and Hank a
curmudgeonly octopus who wants only to
exploit Dory for the transport tag
attached to her fit no no no if I just
take your tag I can take your place on
the transport truck and yeah I mean
that's pretty much it that's the nature
of their friendship
heartwarming right the emotionally
deficient relationship between Hank and
Dory is almost entirely transactional
and deceitful which doubles down on the
film's empathy gap but later finding
Dory hastily tries to switch gears and
that brings us to our second point
shaky narrative structure take a look at
most memorable films and you'll find the
protagonist making a key decision right
at the center of the story it's a moment
that reframes the protagonists
objectives and tests his or her result
some refer to this as the film's
midpoint shift it's no coincidence that
the halfway mark is often a major moment
of self-reflection for the protagonist a
turning point in his or her
I'm waiting there so what happens
halfway through finding dory
well Hank reveals he's got a soft spot
for that loopy blue fish you'll forget
me in a heartbeat kid three heartbeats
not a hard time for getting you though
but where did this sentiment come from
it's surely not earned by any particular
actions or moments in the film itself
because Hank and Dory are never really a
team and unlike Dory and Marlin they're
never really shown enjoying their
adventure and hey come to think of it
Hank isn't even the protagonist here in
any case since Dory and Hank have almost
no moments of genuine connection within
the first half of finding dory Hanks
change of heart towards dory midway
through the film can't help but feel
unearned I don't care contrast this with
the realization Marlin experiences in
the middle of Finding Nemo and maybe he
wouldn't have done it if I hadn't been
so tough on him here Marlin begins to
recognize the error of his
overprotective parenting style and this
realization is a direct result of his
control freak behavior nearly getting
Dory killed throughout Finding Nemo this
midpoint shift and other character
revealing moments are directly motivated
by cause and effect Nemo is motivated to
put his life in jeopardy because he
learns his dad is heroic your dad's been
fighting the entire ocean looking for
you Marlin is motivated to team with
Dory because he realizes Dory can read
later Marlin is motivated to separate
himself from Dory because he thinks his
son is dead in finding Dory however
key moments in the story like Hanks
change of heart towards Dory are largely
motivated by convenience and necessity
they are simply what needs to happen to
move characters from point A to point B
later Dory refers to Hank as acceptable
super cranky but secretly kind of sweet
even though evidence of any such
sweetness is scarce at best but hey in
this movie being an ass is pretty easily
forgiven as long as you pay lip service
to some sort of growth deep into finding
Dory Marlin tells dory ever since I've
met you you've shown me how to do stuff
I never dreamed of doing crazy things
but even this sentiment to seems
unearned because it leverages moments
from the first film in which Dory and
Marlin adventured and grew closer
together rather than from this sequel in
which they are either separated from
each other or annoyed nevertheless this
moment is meant to play as a moment of
self-awareness and maturity from Marlin
which raises the question what is Jory's
key moment of self-awareness in finding
dory you remembered in your own amazing
dory way wow you've got to wait until
the movie is nearly over to find out and
this illustrates finding dory third
setback passive heroism for much of the
film's running time Dory operates as a
passive protagonist one who responds to
events rather than create opportunities
some of this tendency is due to are all
too convenient memory flashes which
handily take the story wherever the
screenwriters needed to go these flashes
and even the occasional undertow are
driven more by chance and proximity then
as a result of personal effort or growth
although sometimes it's almost as if the
film is suggesting Dory's disability can
be willed away this perspective seems a
fishy at best and it doesn't leave Dory
with many opportunities to demonstrate
her ingenuity and development events
often happen to Dory rather than because
of her and that's never a recipe for
great storytelling of course another
cause of Dory's passivity is the nature
of the film's actual environment after
the film's first 20 minutes Dory quite
literally becomes a fish out of water a
status which restricts her movements to
the whims of other characters how much
can we expect our protagonists to be the
master of her own fate when she's being
carried around in coffee pots baby
buggies or a bucket that's labeled
destiny by trading the thrilling blue
ocean of the first film
- the claustrophobic human-centric
clinical spaces of finding dory pixar
ultimately hamstrings the scope of the
story it's able to tell and the degree
to which its protagonist can help tell
it dory then isn't a driver of her own
story
she's a passenger a passive responder -
triggered memories and odd partnership
and very often blind luck but at least
her personal motivation remains
relatively clear she wants to find her
parents and so if we're willing to buy
into the premise of the film we must
simply want to find them - even though
Dory's desire to see her family is very
conveniently triggered by the school of
fish saying the word it's true that
Dora's ultimate objective is never in
doubt but the same can't always be said
for Marlin in this film and it's even
less clear for Nemo who at this point
seems in desperate need of Child
Protective Services and this leads us to
the purposeless entourage I'll pause
here to ask a simple but important
question why does finding Dory involve
all three of these fish and does Nemo's
involvement actually negatively impact
our feelings about Dory and Marlin
that's right Marlin having just a year
earlier across the perilous ocean to
save his only surviving child now agrees
to drag that same child with him - guy
Dory all the way across the ocean again
simply because how can you be talking
about the view and I remembered my pal
no okay but this springs from the
studios need for a sequel not from clear
character behavior ultimately finding
Dory commits the sin of asking Marlin
and emo to undermine so much of what
made Finding Nemo powerful after all the
emotional investment we as an audience
made in Nemo's recovery in Finding Nemo
planning Dory asks us to believe that
Marlin responsible father extraordinaire
is willing to risk his own son's life on
the basis of Dora's hunch about her
parents she hasn't seen in years and no
I'm not being hyperbolic Nemo
really seriously almost dies I mean
couldn't Marlin just find a babysitter
why is Nemo part of this new adventure
why does Dory hoop
zuly cares about nemo safety agree to
pull him along on a dangerous mission to
serve her own personal agenda the film
mostly bypasses these questions and if
we are to enjoy it so must weep but we
should all take a moment here to at
least recognize the weirdness of ending
a fish movie with a car chase on the
freeway and Hey look at that
Dory's a passenger again in her own
movie thanks for watching guys peace if
you want to see some more of our brain
tickling videos click here to check them
out and make sure to subscribe and ring
that bell if you haven't already catch
you next time guys
[Music]